grit is a combination of character
traits such as self-control passion and
perseverance many modern psychologists
educators and parents now believe it's
more important for success in life than
good greater school or an outstanding
intelligence at a Stanford experiment in
the late 1960s psychologist Walter
Mischel put kids in front of one tasty
marshmallow the four-year-old children
were then promised another one if they
had enough willpower not to eat the one
in front of them then they were left
alone for 15 minutes some kids hit below
the table those who were able to delay
their gratification got a second treat
and many years later became more
accomplished adults they were more
healthy at higher test scores at school
and were socially more competent
professor Michelle and the marshmallow
test became famous Angela Duckworth a
popular psychologist later invented the
so called grit scale a questionnaire to
predict success one question do I finish
what I began she then interviewed gifted
businesswoman accomplished scientists
and other successful people she found
out that self-control passion and
perseverance were better indicators for
success than a high IQ score or fine
genes let's examine the reasons behind
this passion leads us to pursue careers
that we love once we love something we
work hard to succeed and as a result can
reach excellence self-control allows us
to wait even if something looks very
attractive this is important because one
day a better option might present itself
and perseverance means we keep fighting
despite obstacles it's essential to
complete projects that then grow our
self-confidence through social
recognition the most gifted minds can't
even start if they lack passion and
inspiration
one way to develop grit is to realize
that we can eliminate our weaknesses
with practice we can learn a new thing
by practicing long enough to see actual
progress but we can also study the lives
of our role models then we understand
that football stars train every day and
receive constant feedback from
professional coaches to develop specific
skills once we internalize that we can
improve our skills we might realize that
we can also practice willpower for
example to change to a vegetarian diet
is hard but if you start small and
trying to cut out beef every Sunday you
might soon realize that you can also
skip chicken during the week and when
that happens you learn that you can grow
willpower like any other muscle in your
body then anything is possible even to
become a vegetarian when we realize that
our brain is like any other muscle that
grows with training then willpower and
self-control are just a matter of
practice and once we practice something
long enough it can become a habit or
even our passion some 2,000 years ago
Aristotle supposedly wrote we are what
we repeatedly do excellence then is not
an act but a habit maybe he was right
what do you think about grit
[Music]
if you like our videos and want to
support our channel visit us at
patreon.com slash sprouts and see if you
want to donate just $1 with your support
we plan to create many more minute
videos about learning and education